video und zwar habe ich die cupcakes
gemacht nein
sallys nicht wieder schwanger nein ich
bin auch aus zum glück sagt dass ich bin
nicht schwanger
es geht um den neuen teil von bridget
jones also wieder ein film rezept und
zwar bekommt bridget jones in dem film
ein baby und fragt sich wer ist der
vater
also ich kann nicht so viel über den
film verraten denn ich habe den film
schon gesehen ich war nämlich auf der
weltpremiere in london eingeladen und
habe ihn da gesehen da waren auch die
hauptdarsteller mit dabei und ein paar
auszüge sehe ich auch am ende des videos
aber jetzt erst mal ganz kurz zu den
muffins also ich habe jetzt mal fix
gemacht und büsche jones weiss in dem
film nicht er zuerst einmal nicht
natürlich ob es ein mädchen oder ein
junge ist und sie wissen nicht wer der
vater ist
deshalb gebe jeden fall ist der film
wirklich super an und ich denke schauen
uns erst mal den trailer an
okay leute wir gehen auf sendungen sehen
versuchs doch mal mit online-dating sec
neulich war ich nach zehn kinder und nur
eine halbe stunde später hatte ich ein
drittel ab prinz andrew hat sein erstes
kinderbuch veröffentlicht hast du
absichtlich gemacht
jetzt mal ehrlich es ist fünf jahre her
dass du dich vom markttrend hast du
solltest mal wieder sex haben
denkt da
sechs stunden gedauert wächst das
puppenspiel bei dem tante world at war
es gibt noch so viel was ich nicht über
ihn weiß wieviel musst du dein wissen es
süß und er ist ein wirklich toller
puppenspieler ok und jetzt mal bitte nur
die paten fantastisch vielleicht ein
kleines küsschen auf die stirn
eigentlich wollte ich das baby
ich kann nicht immer wieder die selben
fehler machen
ich bin schwanger wenn ich stattdessen
neue machen kann
du hast also keine ahnung wer von uns
der vater ist einer von den beiden tagen
ist doch sicher wahrscheinlicher sie
sind beide gleich wahrscheinlich bringen
sie doch den vater mit wenn sie
herausgefunden haben wärs ist das
schicksal hat uns zusammengeführt
alle beide aufhören
ich habe da einen tee mitgebracht wie
sehr ich dir ein grünes musik ich nehme
das darf ich dein handy tragen den
wünschst du dir als vater wie xing
das habe ich früher mal dass ich eines
tages
und du bist gewaltig
wer von ihnen ist der vater
ich war schon gespannt wie viele väter
kommen
also ich denke dass euch der film
gefallen wird jedenfalls ist was diese
endlich mal wieder ein film für mich auf
den film bringen mani matter in einem
lasso angeschaut
bei uns kann man unter ahmed dschabari
anschaut ja das ist ja nett neun frauen
firmen die sich auch in fünf firmen also
der tom und ahmet die fahren und st
ja ja die marke fällig ok
er versteht kein englisch können jeden
fall jedenfalls erkennt in dem trailer
natürlich nicht auf ein mädchen oder ein
junge ist und ich werde euch auch nicht
verraten und wird euch auch nicht
verraten wer der vater ist
deswegen habe ich hier cupcakes gebacken
und zwar könnt ihr die cupcakes zum
beispiel machen wenn ihr selber
schwanger sei oder wenn ihr eine
freundin hab dich schwanger ist oder
eine frau oder eine mama und könnte
dadurch so genau
wir schreiben nicht liest wer der vater
ist nein nicht und wenn ihr es verkünden
wollte was eben das geschlecht ist vom
beta könnte zum beispiel solche muffins
machen und man kennt ja jetzt optisch
rein also gar nicht was wird und das
heißt wenn man sie daran anpasst und
probiert dann sieht man ihnen ist der
teig blau oder rosa von suess sollte
meine cousine gemacht und freunde von
uns schavan und sabine die betreiber für
einen online shop
die haben sich zum beispiel beim dritten
kind gar nicht sagen lassen was es wird
und es dann erst bei der geburt
schon mädchen und jungen und dann war's
egal was es war weil du kannst du lieber
einfluss aber die haben sich wirklich
geheim gehalten
wer am ersten tag der geburt wussten sie
es war junge bei den beiden jedenfalls
zeige ich euch jetzt auf jeden fall wie
man diese muffins herstellt und da wir
starten einfach für den muffin teig
brauche ich 150 zähler von der butter
150 g zucker 190 gramm mehl etwas
vanille extrakt eine prise salz einen
halben teelöffel backpulver und vier
teelöffel natron zweier eine
unbehandelte zitrone und blaue und rosa
ne lebensmittelfarbe ich nehme jetzt
erst einmal alle trockenen zutaten für
den muffins tag braucht ihr auch keine
röhre maschine also kein anderes gerät
oder eine küchenmaschine das geht alles
in einer schüssel unentschieden in die
kaum noch die ganzen bugs rät
mittelrhein also natron backpulver und
dann noch das salz die zutaten verhör
ich jetzt kurz mit einem schneebesen und
wenn ihn nach tron in den teig mit rein
gibt dann muss auf jeden fall auch eine
solche mit rein deswegen kommt später
bei mir noch ein zwei drei spritzer
zitronensaft dazu jetzt kommen schon die
flüssigen zutaten mit ryan also die eier
und die flüssige butter die darf jetzt
auch nicht mehr heiß sein dann noch
etwas vanille extrakt geht natürlich
auch vanille zucker vanille extrakt ist
pures vanille konzentrat und deswegen
etwas geschmacksintensive und jetzt gebe
ich noch zitronenschale mit rein
deswegen muss auch die zitrone
unbehandelt sein damit man die schale
mit patienten und jetzt kommt auch nur
der gelbe teil mit rein denn die weiße
schale darunter dies bitter denn jetzt
noch zwei drei tropfen zitronensaft und
dann kann jetzt die zutaten miteinander
verrühren
also bei natron ist es so da muss auf
jeden fall säure mit rein weil ansonsten
das smartphone gar nicht wirken kann und
bei backpulver ist martin schon mit drin
und auch die säure
das heißt eigentlich könnte man auf das
natron komplett verzichten
aber ich finde dass der teig einfach
noch ein bisschen besser aufgeht aber
falls jetzt keine ahnung habt nehmt ihr
einfach stattdessen noch mal die menge
an aktiva der text jetzt schon fertig
und deshalb ihr ich ihn denn ich möchte
jetzt die hälfte damals beste rosa mache
aber ihr könnt natürlich falls ihr wisst
mädchen oder junge könnt ihr einfach
eine farbe nehmen
da kommen jetzt die verpassten mit rein
und da gibt jetzt so viel mit ein
bisschen farbe gefällt
den fertigen teig fühle ich jetzt mit
einem 1 prozent ihrer in die förmchen 1
die machen jetzt im backofen bei 170
grad ober unterhitze für etwa 20 minuten
gebacken
während die machen sitz noch backen
werde ich schon mal die krim zu bereiten
und zwar geht es dieses mal eine 40 grad
besteht aus pfirsich und weißer
schokolade
wir stehen auch schon die zutaten ich
habe 175 gramm weiße schokolade 240 und
zehn gramm butter werde ich sie erst
einmal die vier sicher nehmen und
schienen
das geht es hier mit einem sparschäler
oder ihr könnt sie auch mit heißem
wasser überbrühen und häuten
und davon werden jetzt etwa 150 gramm
benötigt die für ihre ich
die
das püree fühle ich jetzt in einen topf
dann muss es ein gekocht werden und zwar
so dass viel von der flüssigkeit
verdunstet und dann biegt dann auch etwa
nur noch 100 gramm als am ende frauen
100 gramm 40 köpfe
ihr merkt daran dass es komplett
eingekocht ist wenn er hört dass es
anfängt zu knistern also da recht kaum
mehr flüssigkeit drin
und genau so soll es auch sein lebt
nämlich die weiße kuvertüre und die
kommt der zehn mit rein als im prinzip
ist es jetzt keine echte kanal stellen
kann da eigentlich gerade und schokolade
sondern jetzt einfach eine frucht
schokoladencreme und die schokolade wird
das eingeübte geschmolzen ist und da
gebe ich auch nicht das stück butter mit
dazu
jetzt fühle ich die galashow und stellen
sie in den kühlschrank bis die muffins
auch abgekühlt sind
die muffins und die cremes sind jetzt
abgekühlt und die creme ist jetzt auch
sehr streichfähig also sie ist etwas
fester geworden durch die schokolade da
drin
und jetzt nehme ich immer ein bisschen
von der creme und streicht sie auf dem
muffins drauf und dann müssen die aber
nochmal gekühlt werden
die
die cremes jetzt schon fest und auch
fasst gerd gestrichen
und jetzt keine dekoration machen die
werte gibt ausmaße der schokolade machen
aber in dem fall könnte er jetzt auch
von hand nehmen denn ich habe eine ganze
stunde und davon dann würde sie jetzt
auch nicht auflösen
ich habe die modelle schokolade in rosa
und weiß genommen vermischt und einfach
noch ein bisschen gelber lebensmittel
verpasste eingeführt ein gehört jetzt
soll ich das ganze hier auf etwas becker
stärke aus
und jetzt nämlich ein aussteller etwas
größer als der muffin ist wurden im glas
oder ein schälchen und könnte die kreise
ausstechen
jetzt nehme ich hier einen kreis und
legt ihn drauf man könnte ihn schon mit
den händen leicht andrücken und dann mit
dem von dann klettern glätten und die
überreste könnt ihr dann mit einem
messer wegschneiden
die muffins habe ich jetzt etwa 15
minuten antrocknen lassen und jetzt
werde ich die dekoration herstellen ich
habe mir die gesichter so ein bisschen
vorgezeichnet dann könnte ich hier
nämlich immer gucken was ich gerade
machen möchte und die deko werde gibt
auch aus sondern und modelle schokolade
machen
für das erste motiv werde ich jetzt
jeweils einen runden kreis ausstechen
aus schwarz und zwar wird es jetzt der
geöffnete mund von einem steinigen baby
und die dekoration klebe ich jetzt
jeweils mit essbarem kleber an
jetzt habe ich hier noch einen roten
kreis ausgestochen und schneidet daraus
eine zunge
und die feinheiten mal ich jetzt mit
einem lebensmittel farbstift drauf
die babys fast fertig bei dem anderen
hilft es auf zwei schleifchen und habe
ich da für so eine kleine modell ihr
form aus silikon und dadurch die
schleifen reingedrückt aus modelle
schokolade und zwar nehmen wir da
einfach so ein kleines stück form des
zwischen den händen zu einer kugel und
dann drückt es hier einfach rein und las
kurz antrocknen meine wahl ist schon
getrocknet und die gebe ich jetzt hier
noch dran
und damit die babys noch rote bäckchen
bekommen nämlich noch rote farbe und
pulverisiert einfach so ein bisschen
drauf
so sieht jetzt die fertigen muffins aus
und ich finds echt hübsch muss ich sagen
ich fußball noch ganz viel anderes
machen und falls jetzt geschlecht gleich
verraten wollt könnt ihr die muffins
gleich so dekorieren dass man sieht also
mit rosa röckchen und blau
aber ich finde es sehr schön möchte
schlüssel probiere das immer wieder dem
thema erscheinen sollten zuschauer
manche zuschauer stellt ist warum
mädchen immer rosa ist ja genau ist
eigentlich egal
ich möchte schreien probieren ja
natürlich darf später probieren hast du
ja passen oder ist das dicke kind sollte
ein schmächtiges kennt das problem man
gespannt was ist wird ich guck gar nicht
einig bei sap das weiß auch zufall und
es braucht jedenfalls sagte murat ist
hier probieren und ich erzähle ich noch
was zum gewinnspiel denn ihr könnt auch
dieses jahr etwas gewinnen immer ein
gewisses ich habe dieses gesicht weg
gewesen
morales hat man dazu unique ist ja ich
hab ja auch noch mädchen egal jedenfalls
gibt es auch was zu gewinnen und zwar
könnt ihr 10 x 2 kinokarten gewinn für
den film bridget jones teil 3 petitions
baby dafür habe ich mir jetzt eine frage
überlegt bei der es eigentlich so noch
keine antwort gibt und zwar möglich
gewesen was glaubt ihr denn wer der
vater ist ist es jackpot ist es mag dass
sie also mag dass diese ex-freund und
jack ist der neue dem sie kennenlernt
und er könnte jetzt einfach mal in die
kommentare schreiben mit dem hashtag der
hier unten steht
und einmal bekommt ihr noch ein budget
jones diary
das sind die ersten zwei teile
fangfrische jones mit drin
und die sind auf englisch also ich hab
das alles aus london mitgebracht und das
verlose ich an euch das wird noch
signiert und dann bekommt ihr das
so schnell hat er sich raus geschmeckt
warum würde jetzt beschuldigte sei mit
voller wucht
zumal mit 100 gramm weniger hund
versteht man ja probieren nicht
verschluckt das ganze ding mit einem
quiz also in die kommentare dürft ihr
gerne euren tipp abgeben wer der vater
ist jack oder mark darcy und wir werden
die gewinner zufällig auslosen das heißt
wir verkünden und verraten nicht wer der
vater ist und wie gesagt thema zwei
kinotickets und einer bekommt eben noch
die dvd box mit dazu und ich würde sagen
wir schauen uns jetzt noch ein paar
ausschnitte aus sondern an wenig vater
und habe eine kleine bustour gemacht mit
diesem schönen roten bussen und zwar war
da eine 8
die party im bus und anschließend ihr
noch ein paar ausschnitte vom roten
teppich wo wir eben bei der filmpremiere
waren also ich wünsche euch ganz viel
spaß bei weiter schauen und wir sehen
uns das nächste mal bis dann dabei ach
so und was ich noch unbedingt sagen muss
natürlich ich werde mir den film
natürlich ist auch noch mal auf meiner
freundin da kommt ja bald in die kinos
und dichtem war nicht mit murat bleibt
zu hause
da geht dann mit seinem kumpel noch mal
also bis zum nächsten mal
ich habe kein visum bekommen
um ihrer vergessen dich kompakter machen
nein das sieht doch gut aus hier
wir hatten ja offen